Je suis pas spécialement
maniaque.
Bon, j'aime bien quand
c'est propre et bien rangé...
Bon d'accord, mon appartement
ressemble à une pub IKEA !
(Musique IKEA)
Je suis comme tout le monde,
il y a des choses qui me dégoûtent un petit peu.
Comme la sensation de
la cuvette chaude sous mes fesses
quand je vais aux toilettes
après quelqu'un.
Et je peux pas m'empêcher de m'imaginer
un mec bien dégueulasse
assis juste avant pour me dégoûter.
Ah, il y a des verrues sous mes fesses
qui me grattent !
Parce que j'aime bien me dégoûter.
Je sais pas pourquoi ?
D'ailleurs, quand
je vais dans les toilettes publiques,
j'ai ma petite technique d'autiste
qui consiste à mettre du papier toilette
tout autour de la cuvette.
Alors, je reconnais, sur l'échelle du style,
je suis au plus bas...
Je peux pas pécho en faisant ça.
Et à chaque fois que je fais ça,
je me dis :
Et si tout le monde fait comme moi ?
Dans ce cas là,
ces toilettes sont carrément propre.
Donc pas besoin de mettre
du papier toilette sur la cuvette.
Eh oui !
Mais je suis pas fou.
Hop, troisième couche...
Dans ma tête, tout a basculé
depuis que j'ai vu cette pub...
*Vous me reconnaissez ?
*C'est moi le champignon.
*Je m'incruste sous vos ongles et je m'installe.
*Avec mes copains, nous gagnons du terrain et pas facile de nous déloger !
*Des ongles jaunies, épaissis, décollés? Parlez-en a votre médecin !
Et ils diffusaient cette pub
à l'heure du dîner.
Essaie de manger
en regardant ça.
Moi, ça me dérange pas.
Mmmh...Ils sont bons ces champignons.
En parlant d'hygiène,
on va établir une régle très simple
qu'on va appliquer dès à présent, tout de suite :
tout ce qui touche votre bouche,
vous appartient !
D'accord ?!
Ca ne sert à rien de vouloir partager !
Parfois, on peut esquiver...
J'ai une technique, c'est que
mon cerveau établit les zones sans danger.
Mmmh c'est bon ça,
goûte.
Mmmh...
C'est pas mal.
Quand quelqu'un boit la bouteille et
me la fais boire après,
j'utilise la technique que j'appelle :
boire en Wifi.
Mmmh,
elle est rafraîchissante.
C'est un peu paradoxal car
ma propre crasse, je m'en fous.
Par exemple, sous les souris d'ordinateur
il y a toujours un peu de crasse.
C'est normal,
et on s'en fous.
Par contre,
si c'est la souris de quelqu'un d'autre...
(Dégouts)
(...) J'ai touché ça (...)
C'est ça, casse toi !
L'objet qui attire le plus
la crasse sur la planète terre,
les gamers le savent,
c'est la manette.
Si t'es très très courageux, tu peux même passer
le cure-dent dans la petite rainure
...
Ca, c'est pour les fous.
Et il y a des gens, ils s'en foutent de tout,
rien ne les dégoûtes.
J'aimerai tellement être
comme ces gens là !
Bon, il y a un truc que
je pourrais jamais de la vie, par contre :
embrasser son chien.
NON !
Un chien passe son temps
à renifler les culs d'autres chiens
et à se lécher
les parties génitales !
Donc nan !
N  A  N
NAN
Je reconnais que
je suis pas un exemple d'hygiène, non plus...
Voilà,
je vous avoue un truc...
Parfois,
dans la journée,
je me cure un peu le nez, voilà.
Comme un enfant de 4 ans.
Ah tien...
Mais attention,
c'est pas parce que je suis crade !
Au contraire.
C'est parce que je veux éviter, à tout prix,
cette situation :
Salut, les filles !
Oui c'est moi,
c'est Cyprien de Youtube voilà.
"Star du net",
on peut dire ça comme ça !
Je vais pas vous le cacher,
j'ai quelques petits projets
en termes de cinéma...
J'ai vécu des expériences assez
traumatisantes en termes d'hygiène...
Des images que
je pourrais jamais oublier...
Quand on me postillonne sur le visage,
par exemple.
Si tu veux, c'est un film
où l'histoire n'est pas...
NON, NON,NOOOOOON !!!!
Et là, je me prends le postillon,
et je fais style de rien.
L'histoire n'est PAS
si importante mais par contre...
Ouais...
Alors que dans ma tête...
Je dois prendre une douche !!
Je coupe tout !!
Aaah !!
J'ai vécu un autre truc
du genre.
Un mec qui voulait absolument
me faire écouter un truc....
J'ai un groupe de musique, je peux peut-être te faire écouter?
Ok, si tu veux.
Avec des écouteurs
intra-auriculaires !
Voilà.
Mets ça !
Comme j'ai dis que je voulais bien
écouter son truc, je pouvais pas reculer.
C'est... sympa...
Enlève moi ça !
Ta putain d'cire de merde !
Espèce de gros crado !
Va crever ! Va crever !
Mais sinon,
je suis normal hein.
Je...
Ne partez pas...
Il y a un petit truc là...
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle.
C'est du guacamole.